Davos Seaworth: What's this one now?
Shireen Baratheon: "The Dance of Dragons,
A True Telling" by Grand Maester Munkun.
Davos: Now that sounds like a proper story.
Stannis Baratheon: What's it about?
Shireen: It's the story of the fight between
Rhaenyra Targaryen and her half-brother Aegon
for control of the Seven Kingdoms.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne.
When people started declaring for one of them
or the other, their fight divided the kingdoms
in two.
Brothers fought brothers, dragons fought dragons.
By the time it was over, thousands were dead.
And it was a disaster for the Targaryens as
well.
They never truly recovered.
Stannis: The Dance of Dragons.
Why is that a dance?
Shireen: It's just what they call it.
Stannis: Hmm.
Doesn't make much sense.
Shireen: I think it's poetic.
Joffrey Baratheon: Rhaenyra Targaryen was
murdered by her brother, or rather, his dragon.
It ate her while her son watched.
Stannis: If you'd had to choose between Rhaenyra
and Aegon, who would you have chosen?
Shireen: I wouldn't have chosen either.
It's all the choosing sides that made everything
so horrible.
Stannis: Sometimes a person has to choose.